Testing sites for
the multi-device web
requires a different
set of tools
than desktop web development.
Hi.
I'm Pete, a developer
advocate at Google.
I'm going to show
you my workflow
and how you can
use it to make sure
that your sites look
amazing on any device.
I always start on my desktop
with my browser window
sized to about 400
pixels to mimic
the narrow viewport of a phone.
It also makes it really easy for
me to resize the browser window
to see how things will look
across different viewport
sizes.
Once I've got the basics
down, including my layouts,
my primary break
points, and so forth, I
open up Chrome's built-in
emulation tools and the iOS
simulator.
Emulators and simulators
are great tools.
While they're not
always 100% accurate,
they'll almost always
get the job done.
Chrome's emulation tools allow
you to emulate everything
from screen size, to
device pixel ratio,
to touch, even a
few of the hardware
inputs like geolocation
and the accelerometer.
Starting the emulator is easy.
Simply open up the
dev tools and hit
Escape to show the
console drawer.
Then select the emulation panel.
From there, pick the device
that you want to emulate,
and hit the Emulate button.
Chrome does the
rest automatically.
Now here's a quick tip.
Because mobile devices
are usually in portrait,
dock the dev tools to the
side instead of the bottom
to better use of the space
that you've got on screen.
For iOS testing, I usually
start with the iOS simulator,
which can be downloaded from
Apple's iOS developer center.
It gives me a good idea
of how my pages are
going to look and behave.
Using Chrome's emulation
features and the iOS simulator,
I'm usually able to find and
fix about 80% of the issues
that I come across.
For the other 20%,
I almost always
have to switch to a real device.
Remote debugging allows me to
inspect, debug, and analyze
the on-device experience
with the full suite of tools
that I'm used to, but
on my desktop computer.
To use remote debugging in
Safari, go to Safari's settings
and check the Show Develop
menu in menu bar check box.
Say that 10 times fast.
Next, connect your iOS
device to your Mac via USB,
and then on the iOS
device, open the page
that you want to
debug in Safari.
Now on your desktop,
find the device
in Safari's Develop menu,
and choose the browser page
that you want to debug.
At this point, Safari's Web
Inspector is ready to go.
Sweet.
The initial setup for Chrome
is a little bit more involved,
and it requires that you
enable the USB debugging
in the developer options panel.
If you don't see the
developer options panel,
try going to Settings, then
About Phone, and hit the
build number seven times.
Yeah, seriously, seven times.
Thankfully you only need
to do that once per device.
If you're running
Windows, you'll
probably also need to install
the device drivers as well.
Once you've done that, the
process is much easier.
Connect the device to
your computer via USB,
and open the page that
you want to debug.
Then on your desktop,
open chrome://inspect.
You should now see all the
tabs open on your device
in your desktop browser.
If you don't, make sure that the
Discover USB Devices is checked
and that there aren't any
pop-ups on the device asking
for permission.
You can even access files served
locally from your computer
or from a private network
with port forwarding.
Chrome remote debugging
also supports screencasting.
Click the screencast icon in
the upper right-hand corner
and Chrome brings the
experience of your device
into your dev tools
window, allowing
you to keep your attention on
one screen instead of having
to switch back and forth,
and back and forth,
and back and forth between
the device and dev tools.
Now keep in mind,
screencasting captures
screenshots and sends
them to your desktop.
So there is a small
cost overhead involved.
Remote debugging is
amazing if you've
got the devices you need,
but what if you get a bug
report for a device
that you don't have
or that isn't available
where you live?
Or better yet, you want to
automate some of your tests.
For that, I use one of the
remote testing services
like BrowserStack, Sauce
Labs, or DeviceAnywhere.
These remote testing services
offer cloud-based access
to real and emulated
browsers and devices.
Through these services I
can interact with the device
as if it were right
there in front of me.
My interactions are
carried through directly
to the device or emulator.
Some of these services
even offer APIs
that I can use for
automated testing.
For example, unit tests,
end-to-end tests, or screenshot
capturing for visual
regression tests.
Now that's my
web-development workflow.
I start by using
my desktop browser
for my initial iteration.
Next I move to
emulators and simulators
for the bulk of my work.
I pull out real devices for
polishing in verification.
And when I don't have
the device I need,
I try and find it on one of
the remote testing services.
Then I'm ready to ship.
[? Whoohoo. ?]
If you're not making
sure that your site works
for the multi-device
web, why not?
I've just shown
you three easy ways
that you can get started today.
Thanks for watching.